distracted driver awareness month was
actually last month and i did i i meant
to talk about it but like a lot of us i
got distracted but seriously pam shadle
fisher from the governor's highway
safety association she says more and
more of us are at least owning up to
being distracted
you know half of the driving public is
saying hey you know i admit it i do take
a call i text i do this while i'm
driving it does increase the risk
substantially and these are you know
there these are preventable things you
can stop this behavior we can prevent
these crashes from happening and we can
save lives people are admitting it what
else can we do
people might say well yeah i mean i have
an anti-texting law but you know i still
do it but many people don't we know that
laws do help with compliance but they
also help with enforcement we need to
give officers the ability to pull over
that driver if they are engaged in that
risky behavior
so the governor's highway safety
association that's a nationwide group
they're working to connect each state's
highway safety program so not associated
directly with the administration of
nevada governor steve sisolak i also
talked with a safety strategist from
general motors and i'll share her
thoughts in an upcoming report the
meantime please buckle up drive
carefully and put down that phone some
driving to crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com